[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم عبر الامين العام للامم
المتحده بان جيمون عن قلقه من وقوع عمليات
قتل وخطف وتدمير للممتلكات في المناطق
التي استعادتها القوات العراق وميليشيات
مواليه لها من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وحث
بان الحكومه العراقيه على ضمان حمايه
المدنيين في المناطق التي تشهد عمليات
عسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي دواعي قلق الامين العام
للامم المتحده من افعال القوات العراقيه
والميليشيات المواليه
لها ما هو المطلوب دوليا لحمايه العراقيين
السنه في المناطق التي تخضع لسيطره القوات
العراقيه والميليشيات
[موسيقى]
الشيعيه طلب الامين العام للامم المتحده
بان جمون حكومه بغداد بان تكون جميع
الميليشيات المنضوي تحت لواء الحشد الشعبي
تحت سيطرتها وان تحاسب مرتكبي المخالفات
بحق سكان المناطق المحرره من سيطره تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وعبر بان عن قلقه من
عمليات اعدام تحدث خارج القانون ومن
عمليات خطف وتدمير للممتلكات ترتكبها
الميليشيات الشيعيه التي تشارك الى جانب
قوات الحكومه في استعاده السيطره على
المناطق السنيه من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل بين اخر زياره لبانك مون الى
بغداد في تموز يوليو الماضي وزيارته
الحاليه اليها تسعه اشهر حفلت بسيء
الاخبار من العراق قتلا ونزوح وانتهاكات
اكتفت ازاءها الامم المتحده بالاع ي عن
القلق والانشغال لكنها اليوم تبدو وكانها
قررت مخاطبه المسؤولين العراقيين مباشره
وبحزم بشان ما ترتكبه ميليشيات الحشد
الشعبي من جرائم بحق السكان في المناطق
السنيه التي يتم استعادتها من تنظيم
الدوله
الاسلاميه يجب ان يظل المتطوعون الذين
يساندون قوات الامن العراقيه تحت سيطره
الحكومه اما بالنسبه للادعاءات بارتكاب
جرائم وسوء معامله او اي نوع من انواع
الانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان في العراق فقد
تم التحري عنها ويجب ان يحاسب
مقترفيها منذ الصيف الماضي واجهت المنظمه
الدوليه والقوى الكبرى اتهامات بعدم
التوازن ففي غمره دعمها المطلق لحكومه
بغداد ضد تنظيم الدوله اكتفت دائما بادانه
ممارسات التنظيم والصمت عن انتهاكات
الميليشيات الشيعيه والقوات
التي منها ما يرقى الى جرائم حرب فتلك
الميليشيات التي تتلقى معظمها الدعم من
ايران اقدمت على ارتكاب عمليات اعدام
جماعيه بحق السنه فضلا عن احراق منازلهم
ودور
العباده قبل يوم واحد اتهمت هيومن رايتس
واتش مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم
المتحده بالتغافل عن التصدي لما سمته
انتهاكات فظيعه ترتكبها الميليشيات
الشيعيه وقوات الامن العراقيه ضد المدنيين
بينها اعمال قتل خارج نطاق القضاء وتعذيب
واختطاف وتهجير قصري ولم يفت المنظمه ان
تذكر بما توصلت اليه من استنتاجات مشابهه
في اعقاب تحقيقها في الانتهاكات التي تلت
انسحاب تنظيم الدوله من بلده امرلي في
محافظه صلاح الدين شهر ايلول سبتمبر
الماضي حينها قالت في تقرير سمته التدمير
بعد التحرير ان الميليشيات الشيعيه نهبت
ممتلكات المدنيين السنه الذين فروا من
القتال واحرقت منازلهم ومحالهم التجاريه
ودمرت ما لا يقل عن قريتين بالكامل افعال
تتكرر الان وربما على نحو اوسع في معركه
تكريت وفق هيومان رايتس وتش منظمه العفو
الدوليه ايضا سبق وان وصفت تلك الجرائم
بالعمل الممنهج ذي الابعاد الطائفيه وليس
مجرد تصرفات فرديه كما يعتبرها رئيس
الوزراء حيدر العبادي الذي تصاعدت في عهده
سطوه الميليشيات مع ان تكليفه كان بالاساس
للقضاء على تلك الممارسات وفق توافق عراقي
بضغوط دوليه انذاك واذ تجمع تلك
الانتهاكات بين تصاعدها باضطراد وتوسع
نطاقها الجغرافي وطابعها المنهجي ضد مكون
بعينه فانها لا تبعث فقط
على ايقاظ الفتنه الطائفيه بل على تغيير
النسيج الديموغرافي برمته فهل يمتد بصر
الامم المتحده الى ما يحجبه غمار المعارك
في
العراق معنا في هذه الحلقه من بغداد السيد
هشام السهيل رئيس لجنه المصالحه والمسائله
والعداله في البرلمان العراقي وعضو اتلاف
دوله القانون ومن اربيل السيد ناجح
الميزان الامين العام للمؤتمر التاسيسي
لاقليم صلاح الدين من عمان السيد نزار
السمرائي المستشار بالمركز العراقي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكم جميعا
والسؤال للسيد السهيل سيد هشام السيد بانج
مون قلق من عمليات قتل وخطف واعتداءات
وانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان الى اخر ما
سمعناه في التقرير وفي تصريحات السيد بن
جيمون كيف تعلق على
هذا شكرا لك ولضيوفك الكرام بالحقيقه
موضوع الميليشيات وما تحدث عنها بعض
الوسائل الاعلام وبالتاكيد اكيد هناك
السيد بانكيمون تطرق الى هناك ميليشيات
انا انا اقول لك بكل صراحه ان ما موجود
يجب ان نرجع بحقيقه للتاريخ نتكلم عن
تاريخ نشوء هذه المجاميع التي دافعت عن
العراق التي تسمى اليوم ميليشيات بعد فتوى
المرجعيه نعم هناك جاءت ناس متطوعين بشكل
يعني كبير وكبار وصغار سن وهؤلاء كلهم
تجمعوا لغرض الدفاع عن العراق او عن بغداد
خصوصا بعد ما داعش هددت بغداد ولكن هذه
كانت لفتره قصيره ومن ثم الدوله انتبهت
الى هذا الموضوع وقم وتم تنظيم هذه
المجاميع المتطوعه للدفاع عن العراق
وتم انشاء هيئه تسمى هيئه الحشد الشعبي
وهذه الهيئه ضمت كل الذين يقاتلون في هذه
المحافظات نحن ندري نحن ندري والعراقيون
يدرون تاريخ ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي نعرف
جميعا منشاها و كيف بس خليني خليني اوضح
خليني نعم نعم فاهم بس خليني اوضح لك
الموضوع فما جرى حقيقه في تكريت هذا مثال
على احترام حقوق الانسان بالكامل وهذا
توصيه الحكومه العراقيه والمرجعيات
بالتاكيد الذي حدث في منطقه دياله نعم بعد
تحرير بعض المناطق نعم اتت اناس لا نعرفهم
ولا ينتمون الى الحشد الشعبي وسمعنا ان
ارتكبت بعض الاعمال حقيقه الاجراميه التي
لازالت تحقيق جاري في الموضوع والحكومه
جاده في التحقيق وكشف ملابسات الحادث اما
ما يحدث اليوم اليوم الحشد الشعبي يمثل كل
اطياف المجتمع العراقي هناك من من السنه
ومن الشيعه انا انا حاليا امامك انا شيخ
عشيره بني تمي اليوم لدي في في عشيرتي سنه
وشيعه اليوم كلهم متكاتفين ويقاتلون داعش
انا اتمنى ان نبتعد عن هذا الخطاب ونتكلم
بالخطاب العراقي الذي يؤمن ان وحده العراق
هي المهم عندنا ووحده كل والطوائف تكون
كلها باتجاه وحده العراق ونتمنى على كل
الاخوان ان يدعموا هذا التوجه ويدعموا
الناس الذين يريدون ان يحرروا العراق فعلا
من داعش سيد ناجح الميزان ما مدى واقعيه
الكلام الذي ذكره السيد
السهيل تحيه لك وقناه الجزيره ولضيفك
الكريمين
طبعا السيد النائب هو اكيد يعني لازم
يتكلم بهذا الموضوع لا سما وانه
ا عضو في مجلس النواب لكن الحقاق غير هذا
الحقائق اليوم يعني بايكي مون قلق من
اشياء سمع بها هي واحد على الاف من ما
يحدث في المناطق اليوم في الدور وصل العدد
تفجير البيوت البيوت غير ملغمه بالمناسبه
يعني ها احصائيات ارجو ال تثير يعني عندما
نذكر ارقام لا تثير فزع الاخرين ها حقائق
لا توجد داعش لم تحدث معركه في الدور
انسحبت داعش قبل ان ياتي الحشد ب ب 10000
م لا توجد بيوت ملغمه لا فكتاب حزب الله
وصلت بالتفجير طبعا بعد ما سلبت كل
الاموال ولم تبقى الا الحيطان
620 دار على عقار تم تفجيرها يعني كتائب
حزب الله في الدور ليس لديها عمل الا
التفجير واعتقال من تجده كانه رجل كهل وصل
العدد المفقودين بحدود 150 واحد اخذوا
عوائلهم واخذوهم اخذوا الرجال بمكان لا
يعرف اين والنساء في منطقه المعتصم هذا
اولا في منطقه ال جلان في الكواكب بسلو
حوالي 120 الى 130 شخص لا يعلمون اين
والتجريف على ساق وقدم البيوت المزارع
سيارات الان مدفونه تحت الارض يعني اهلها
دفنوها سيارات حديثه تحت الارض وبنوا
عليها
سقوف واخفها لانه هناك قاعده في البوعجيل
في سمره البياز على اليوم اللي هي بجانب
العلم حوالي 120 بيت لا يوجد بها اناس سوى
البيوت تم اخذ كل ممتلكات وتفجيره ها
القضيه مو جو العبا ولا اتهامات هاي ارقام
وستظهر عندما يعود الناس اذا سمحوا الحشد
اذا سمح الحشد لعوده الاهالي الى منطقتهم
لا كما يحدث في جرفه صخر وفي عزيز بلد وفي
يثرب وفي في الجلام وفي الدور وفي المجمع
وفي البوعجيل وغير البوعجيل وغير الاماكن
اليوم تفجير ممنهج قتل
ممنهج والحجه طبعا بالمناسبه يقولون اللي
يسلبون اموال الناس ويخبرون على اهلهم عند
ما يجدون رقم تليفونه ويحصلون عليه يقولوا
لهم هذا الاثاث احنا راح ناخذ هاي
الممتلكات هاي
ممتلكاتنا من زمن صدام انتم استوليت عليها
واحنا اليوم ناخذها هذا حقنا تحت هال
الشعار هذا انه هذه اموالنا سرقت منا في
زمن صدام اليوم ناخذها هذا الموضوع اللي
ده يحدث اليوم وعلى المرجعيه وعلى السيد
العبادي وعلى السيد النائب ان يشخصوا هذه
الحالات ويؤدب السيئين اذا كانوا السيئين
يهجرون مناطق بالاف الدوانم هذا هذا تعك
عن سليمان بيك 50 قريه من بغداد الى كركوك
50 قريه اقل قريه بحدود 500 بيت بجدها لا
تجد اليوم شاهد عيان من بغداد الى كركوك
لا يوجد يعني ذكرت ذكرت ما يكفي ذكرت ما
يكفي سيد نزار السمرائي السيد بن جيمون او
رجل القلق كما يصفه منتقدو الامم المتحده
يقول ان على الحكومه العراقيه ان تجري
تحقيقا مستقلا في هذه في هذه المزاع
بالانتهاكات هل تعتقد ان بالامكان واقعيا
في المرحله الحاليه ان تجري الحكومه
العراقيه مثل هذا التحقيق السيد هشام
السيل بالمناسبه يقول ان الحكومه تجري
بالفعل هذا
التحقيق تحيه لك ولضيفك الكريمين ولمشاهده
قناه
الجزيره يا سيدي يبدو ان الامم المتحده
استيقظت اخيرا من غفوه طويله منذ ان كانت
قد صودرت من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتسترت على كل الجرائم التي
ارتكبت في العراق لانها لم تكن قادره على
ان تفعل شيئا بسبب وجود الفيتو الامريكي
في مجلس الامن على العموم منظمه هيومان
رايتس وتش منظمه العفو الدوليه اشارت الى
ما يقع في العراق من جرائم
وانتهاكات وعمليات قتل على الهويه وتجريف
البساتين وهدم الدور واختطاف وتهجير لناخذ
واقعه لم يذكرها السيد ناجح الميزان وان
كان قد تحدث بالتفصيل عن شواهد كثيره
ولكنني اشير الى قضيه واحده وهي
مسجد قصبه شروين في ناحيه بروانه في قضاء
المقداديه 70 مواطنا قتلوا بدم بارد بعد
صلاه العشاء على الرغم من انهم كانوا
يؤدون صلاتهم بمناسبه المولد النبوي
الشريف من من هو الذي سيجري التحقيق هل هو
القاتل لا يمكن ان افترض ان من تستر على
الجريمه حينما كان قاسم سليمان وهادي
العامري موجودين في هذه المنطقه يمكن ان
يستطيع لا رئيس الوزراء ولا السيد النائب
الذي تحدث من بغداد الان ولا اي شخص اخر
يمكن ان يستجيب الى متطلب الحقيقه منظمه
هيومان رايتس وتش اشارت الى ان الذين
قتلوا في هذه المنطقه في بروانه بالم
المقداديه هم
72 شخصا وليس 70
فقط نعم انا ذكرت الرقم التقريبي وان
هنالك ارقام اكثر من هذا الرقم ولكن حينما
قلت 7ب هم ممكن ان يكونوا اكثر من ذلك
بكثير على العموم هذه جريمه موصوفه كامله
الاركان وينبغي على الامم المتحده ان
تلاحق هذا الملف لانني اظن ان من ارتكبها
ما زالوا على راس السلطه التنفيذيه وهم
نواب في المجلس النيابي مثل هادي العامري
قائد فيلق بدر من الذي جاء بقاسم سليماني
للعراق يا سيدي لماذا لم تحتج حيدر
العبادي على وجود قاسم سليماني في العراق
وهو الذي يقول لا يوجد الا مستشارون هل ان
المستشارين يستطيعون ان يفعلوا كل هذه
الجرائم ما حصل في دياله على سبيل المثال
ما حصل في جرف الصخر جرائم مكت مكتمله
الاركان
ارتكبتها منظمات او ميليشيات ارهابيه كفيل
بدر وكفيل وعصاب اهل الحق وحزب الله
و الخراساني وغير ذلك من ميليشيات كثيره
تعد بالعشرات يا سيدي الامر لا اظن انه
اكثر من صيحه في واد من قبل الامين العام
للامم المتحده وان وعده المسؤولون
العراقيون فلن يفعل يفعل شيئا وسيعود
محملا بكثير من الوعود من دون ان يجد اي
وعد طريقه الى التنفيذ ارجو منكم ان تبقوا
معي مشاهدينا الاعزاء فاصل قصير نناقش
بعده الاجراءات الضروريه دوليا لحمايه
السنه القاطنين في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات العراقيه والميليشيات
الشيعيه السائره في ركابها ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء
في هذه الحلقه الحلقه التي تناقش دواعي
قلق الامين العام للامم المتحده من
الانتهاكات التي ترتكبها القوات العراقيه
والميليشيات الشيعيه بحق المدنيين السنه
في العراق واعود الى ضيفي من بغداد السيد
هشام السهيل النائب في البرلمان العراقي
عن ائتلاف دوله القانون سيد سيد هشام يعني
ربما يتندر العراقيون اذا سمعوا ان
الحكومه العراقيه هي التي تجري التحقيقات
في هذه الانتهاكات كما ذكرت يعني هل رايت
قاتلا يدين نفسه هل رايت معتديا او سارقا
او خاطفا
يحكم على نفسه بالادانه او يعاقب
نفسه اولا هذا كلامك يعني ان الحكومه هي
التي قتلت لان الحكومه هي التي تحقق وليس
جهات اخرى هذا هذا واحد الثانيا اخوي
العزيز بالنسبه لموضوع بروانه بروانه لم
يكن واتحدى ان يكون شخص واحد من الحشد
الشعبي كانوا موجودين في بروانه بروانه ما
جرى في بروانه حقيقه وهذا ما تحقق به
الحكومه العراقيه لانه لم يكن هناك اي شخص
من الحشد الشعبي هذه واحده ثانيا موضوع
التجريف والقتل وما شابه ذلك يعني انا ما
اعرف هل نحن في حرب ام في نزهه هذه حرب يا
اخوان يعني انت لما تبدا في حرب ماذا ماذا
تتامل الحرب ممكن ان يكون بها خسائر ولكن
موضوع انه بيوت هدمت بيوت هجرت بيوت فجرت
يعني يا اخوان وين هذا بس اريد افهم انا
اريد اصل وياكم الى حقيقه وبالمناسبه خلي
يفهم ضيفك الكريمين انه انا شخص مستقل ضمن
دوله القانون ولست متحزب الىي جهه ولكن
علينا ان نتكلم بالحقائق انا اتمنى على
الاخوان ان ياتون الى بغداد ونحن نرحب بهم
ويتفضل معنا هنا ويشرفون على التحقيق وانا
مستعد ان اكلم الحكومه العراقيه وان يكون
هم موجودين ووسائل الاعلام اهلا وسهلا بها
واذا واذا كان هناك تقصير من اي جهه
بالتاكيد سنحاسب بقوه ولكن انه موضوع
ذكروا انه هادي العامري وغيره هادي
العامري رجل مقاتل يقاتل اليوم الدفاع عن
بلده يعني ما اعرف كل الاحوال في كل
الاحوال سيد هشام السهيل الذي قال هذا في
الاساس او الذي يعني اثار بشانه هذا الجدل
وتصريحات الامين العام للامم المتحده الذي
ليس هو في الاخير ليس عراقيا ولا ينتمي
لاي حزب عراقي وفي الوقت ذاته يردد ما
جاءت به تقارير لمنظمات تابعه للامم
المتحده ومنظمه هيومان رايتس وتش وغير من
المنظمات المعنيه بحقوق الانسان بمعنى ان
هذه الاتهامات جاءت من هيئات مستقله ولم
تاتي من السيد نزار السمرائي وليست من
السيد ناجح الميزان
وحسب نعم اكيد لكنه هل هذه المنظمات كانت
موجوده في ارض الواقع ام هي نحن نعرف كلنا
ماذا يجري في موضوع هذه المنظمات المستقله
الدوليه الممات التي المنظمات المستقله
بحجه انها غير موجوده في ارض الواقع
والموجودون في ارض الواقع
تنكر اتهاماتهم على من نعتمد في تحقيق
كهذا على سبيل المثال او استقصاء لما يجري
على الارض في الع العزيز انا عملت انا
عملت في مجال حقوق الانسان منذ عام
2004 وعملت كثيرا وكنت مديرا عاما في حقوق
الانسان على كل حال هذا الموضوع المنظمات
هم يعرفون نعرف ماذا يشي الح الشعبيه ان
تكون انت عملت في منظمات حقوق الانسان او
حتى عملتها في الامم المتحده ما علاقه هذا
بالنقاش استاذي لانه انا اعرف كيف تكتب
هذه التقارير وكيف تقدم والى اخره من
التفاصيل نحن في غن عنها اما موضوع ارجاع
النازحين اليوم العلم رجعوا الى الى
اماكنهم واليوم الذين يقاتلون في تكريت
بالمناسبه يجب ان لا نقفل ذلك هم هم اهل
تكريت اليوم موجودين في المقدمه يقاتلون
هناك الجبور يقاتلون هناك كثير من من
العشائر الموجوده في تكريد موجودين اخوان
يعني نحن لماذا نتكلم بهذا بهذا حقيقه
بهذا يعني الموضوع الذي لا يقدم ولا يؤخر
سوى اثاره النعرات للاسف الطائفيه والتي
تؤدي الى عدم استقرار العراق سم اي نعرات
هل تريد من الناس ان يقتلوا ولا يضج
بالشكو هل تستخر عليهم ان يعلو صراخهم
عندما يذبحون او يهجرون من بيوتهم هل هذا
كثير عليهم دعني اطرح السؤال على السيد
نجح الميزان يعز علينا قتل لظه
لهان السيد هشام السهيل وجه اليك والى
السيد نزار السمرائي والى المتحدثين في
هذه القضيه دعوه لكي تاتوا الى بغداد
وتشرفوا على عمليات التحقيق بانفسكم حتى
تضمنوا نزاهتها ما ردك على هذه
الدعوه ردي للشيخ النائب هشام السهيل وهو
شيخ فعلا شيخ عشيره بني تميم هناك 1800
عائله من عشيرته من البو حشمه من يثرب
يسكنون الان في منطقه عربد في السليمانيه
لا تسمح لهم حكومه بلد مو حكومه المحافظه
حكومه بلد لا تسمح لهم بالعوده لم تبقى
لهم بيوت انا ادعوه ان يزور بيوت عشيرته
يعني اللي هو شيخهم يا حب ذا لو يشاركنا
السيد هشام سيل ويرجع لنا بس ابناء عشيرته
كل شي ماردين من عنده اذا استطاع السيد
هشام سهيل ان يرجع البو حشمه وخليه يذهب
الى عربد ويشوف البو حشمه ويشوف بيوتهم ش
ايش بقى عندهم ايش ظل عندهم من املاك انا
ذاك ما نحتاج تحق طلع بالجزيره من خلال
جزيرت سيد سيد هشام السيل الم تقدم
الميليشيات الشيعيه المنضوي او السائره في
ركاب الحكومه العراقيه على اعدام نازحين
من ناحيه يثرب من قضاء بلد بمحافظه صلاح
الدين وفجرت مساجد في دياله امام انظار
الاجهزه الامنيه وجرى الاعدام في الحسينيه
شمال بغداد سبعه من عشيره البو حشمه كما
تحدث ضيفنا من اربيل وسبعه اخرين من عشيره
المزاريع الم يحدث
هذا يا اخي خليه اتكلم على موضوع البو
حشمه لان الاخ كلفنا انه موضوع البو حشمه
انا متابع الموضوع بكل تفاصيله الموضوع
مختلف تماما ولا دخله للميليشيات في هذه
المنطقه وهو يعلم هذه المنطقه بها بني
تميم من السنه والشيعه ولكن المشكله
عشائريه بحته هناك اشخاص قتلوا في هذه
العش في عشيره بني تميم نفسهم قتلوا من من
بعض الاشخاص في بو حشمه البو حشمه ليست
جميعهم الذين خارج الموضوع هم عدد قليل
جدا لا يتجاوز هذا عدد بسيط ولكن نحن نعمل
على اعاده الاخرين الابرياء وسيعودون
قريبا وستسمع ذلك قريبا جدا نحن نعمل منذ
فتره على هذا الموضوع واخوان اخرين معنا
من بنب واليوم قريبا جدا سنحل هذا
الموضوع نز السمرا بالقدوم الى بغداد
والمشاركه في هذا التحقيق او الاشراف على
هذا التحقيق الذي تسميه نزيها ومستقلا سيد
نزار السمرائي ما
ردك لو انه يوجه دعوه لمنظمه دوليه منظمه
حقوقيه
باشراف الامم المتحده ان تجري
التحقيق على شرط ان يكون تحقيقا نزيها
وشفافا وبعيدا عن تاثيرات الميليشيات
الشيعيه
وتاثير ما يسمى بالحشد الشعبي وتاثير
الحكومه وتاثير حتى مجلس النواب وحتى
تاثير السلطه القضائيه في العراق اذا ما
سمح لمثل هذه اللجنه فسوف نرى شيئا صارخا
يشبه ما جرى في في رواندا وما جرى في
يوغسلافيا السابقه وسيحال ان وجد قانون
دولي عادل جميع الجنات من المنفذين والامر
بالجرائم او الساكتين والمتجر عليها الى
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه بموجب المشكله
بموجب اتفاقيه روما لعام
1998 يا سيدي ضيفك من بغداد يتحدث عن
مدينه فاضله لا وجوده لها الا في الكتب في
كتب الفارابي وكتب افلاطون وغيرها من
المدن الامين العام للامم المتحده ايضا
سيد السمرائي ابد قلقه من عدم قدره
الحكومه العراقيه والمنظمات الاغاثه على
رعايه اثنين ونص مليون نازح من منازلهم
جراء العمليات العسكريه هل هي هل الحكومه
العراقيه غير قادره ام غير راغبه في
تقديرك هي غير راغبه اصلا و حتى اذا كانت
راغبه يوما ما فانها غير لا تمتلك
الامكانات يا سيدي اعطيك رقما بسيطا
يوم قبل ثلاثه ايام طلبت وزاره الدفاع من
وزاره الماليه تخصيص 65 مليون دولار بشان
المستلزمات الطبيه لان حوادث الجروح او
القتل التي تجرى في الاشتباكات او في
المعارك
الاخيره تتطلب وجود هذا المبلغ لكن وزاره
الماليه اجاب
لا يتوفر لدينا مبلغ الا 5 ملايين دولار
وعلى الجيش او وزاره الدفاع والداخليه ان
ترتب امرهما من دون ان يعتمد على وزاره
الماليه هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى من جهه
اخرى الحكومه لا تمتلك رواتب واظن ان
مرتبات الموظفين لا وجود لها لان الخزينه
مفلسه بسبب السياسات الخاطئه لل الحكومات
المتعاقبه منذ الاحتلال وحتى اليوم وخاصه
حكومه نور المالكي شزي شكرا جزيلا لك
السيد نزار السمرائي المستشار بالمركز
العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه واشكر كذلك
ضيفنا من اربيل السيد ناجح الميزان الامين
العام للمؤتمر التاسيسي لاقليم صلاح الدين
واشكر ضيفنا من بغداد السيد هشام السهيل
رئيس لجنه المصالحه والمسائله والعداله في
البرلمان العراقي وعضو ائتلاف دوله
القانون بهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا الاعزاء هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده فيما وراء
خبر جديد السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]